[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tortenwelt ich bin zwar hier gerade
fleißig am Backen und zwar gibt's bei
mir Pfefferkuchen Plätzchen aber die
sind jetzt hier nicht fürs Rezept
sondern ich werde die Plätzchen
mitnehmen auf die Messe übermorgen also
jetzt kommende Donnerstag am 30 Oktober
bin ich nämlich auf der offertamesse in
Karlsruhe das eine Verbrauchermesse da
kann jeder von euch hinkommen der sich
für mich interessiert oder auch für
andere Stände und ich werde dort sein
von 10 bis 18 Uhr und zwar ist das die
Halle 4 das ist die Halle der Frau in
derarena der Frau aber auch Männer
dürfen kommen und ich freue mich wenn
ihr kommt denn es gibt nicht nur leckere
Sachen zum Probieren ich zeige euch auch
wie ich ein paar Sachen dekoriere ein
paach Tipps und Tricks ihr könnt mir
Fragen stellen zu YouTube Youtube zu
Facebook ihr könnt meine neuen
Produktneuheiten sehen die ich aus dem
Shop habe und wir haben natürlich auch
die tollsten Sachen aus dem Shop mit
dabei das heißt ihr könnt die dann auch
mal vor Ort sehen und nicht nur online
in unserem Onlineshop und ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr da vorbeikommt also wie
gesagt am Donnerstag jetzt übermorgen
von 10 bis 18 Uhr bin ich da und was
ganz besonderes die liebe Nicole von
nicools Zuckerwerk ist auch da und das
ist schon eine sehr gute Freundin von
mir und immer wenn ich so eine Aktion
habe unterstützt sie mich auch sehr das
ist ein richtiger Goldschatz die Nicole
jetzt fange ich gleich an zu weinen weil
die so lieb ist ja die Nicole wird auch
dabei sein obwohl sie sogar ihren Fuß
noch verletzt hat und ich freue mich da
wirklich sehr darüber und freue mich
wenn ihr alle kommt und wir uns auch mal
kennenlernen dürfen den Kanal von Nicole
verlinke ich euch übrigens hier oben da
gibt's nämlich auch ganz leckere Rezepte
tolle Motivtorten und richtig gute
Anleitungen auch für 3D Torten da müsst
Ihr unbedingt mal vorbeischauen und hier
zeige ich euch einfach mal ein paar
Sachen die ich jetzt schon vorbereitet
habe